you heard a lot about the kids in cages
during trump's term
that was obviously a ridiculous false
narrative talking about false narratives
uh police shootings i think that's
number one
on the list of false narratives from the
media but kids in cages the only reason
that isn't number one is because the
consequences of that lie
have not been nearly as dire as the
consequences of the police shooting lie
that's a simple lie
and one of the reasons that you knew it
was a lie from the beginning when the
left was going on about kids in cages
and how worried they are about it and
and all of that one of the reasons you
knew it was a lie
it goes back to what we were just
discussed that there's no way
these people actually give a damn anyway
any that's uh that's a a hint for
everybody
anytime someone on the left is
pretending to care about children
you know something is up because they
don't actually care
there's got there's something else going
on here something is wrong
any time the someone on the left is
pretending to care about children
and probably what they're saying is
completely bogus as it was here so
uh the kids and cage narrative was was
bogus um
and but it was pushed by the media and
democrats and biden himself
interesting thing now though is that
biden himself is keeping
migrant kids in the same places that
trump is keeping them
jenn saki was asked about this at a
press conference
and here's how that went and to ensure
the health and safety of these kids
hhs took steps to open an emergency
facility to add capacity
where these children can be provided the
care they need while they are safely
before they are safely placed with
families
and sponsors so it's a temporary
reopening during covet 19.
our intention is very much to close it
but we want to ensure that we can follow
covet protocols as we as we as
unaccompanied minors come into the
united states but it's the same facility
that was open
for a month in the trump administration
summer 2019
that is when joe biden said under trump
there have been horrifying scenes at the
border of kids being kept in cages and
kamala harris said
uh basically babies in cages is a human
rights
abuse being committed by the united
states government so how is this any
different than that we very much feel
that way
uh and these are facilities let me be
clear here
one there's a pandemic going on i'm sure
you're not suggesting that we have
children right next to each other uh in
ways that are not coveted safe are you
i'm suggesting that kamala harris said
that
this facility putting people in this
facility was a human rights abuse
committed by the united states
government and jill biden said
under trump there have been horrifying
scenes of border
uh at the border of kids being kept in
cages now it's not under trump it's
under binding
this is not kids being kept in cages
this is
this is kids this is a facility that was
opened
that's going to follow the same
standards as other hhs facilities it is
not a replication
certainly not though that's that is
never our intention of replicating the
immigration policies of the past
administration oh okay
all right well well fine then never mind
they're not cages they're facilities now
you see there's a clear difference it's
exactly the same
situation the exact same place
everything's the same
but uh not cages they're facilities
that's all yeah well they were
facilities all along
and yes that's see that's that's the
point um
and that's why this the tricky thing you
run into anytime you're trying to hold
democrats to their own standard
or to the standards that they've applied
to you
because we can we can criticize biden
for this immigration policy
because he criticized trump for the same
and mischaracterized and lied about it
but we're not saying that what's
happening right now is wrong like
of course the kids are here especially
if they're
unaccompanied you know what else are you
gonna do
just send them off into the wild world
by themselves
you have to when when people are coming
here
and especially if they're coming here
illegally you got to do something
and if we're talking about kids you have
to have a place for them
and we also know to complicate matters
that um
that oftentimes the adults
with the children may pose as parents
but oftentimes are not actually the
parents this could be a trafficking
situation you don't know
you don't know you have no way of
knowing
this is the situation that you know
that the law enforcement officials
immigration officials are put in
because of the decision to you know
among illegal
immigrants to do that to commit that
crime
and to involve kids in it
so there's no perfect answer
there there's there's a lot of times
there's no happy conclusion you have to
do something
and it makes sense to have yes
facilities
so we're not criticizing that however we
also can't let you
get away with this without pointing out
what you're doing
so that's the that's the balancing act
that we always find ourselves in when
dealing with the hypocrisy of the left
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated